[Music]
Mexican border is very unprotected by
our laws we have horrible horrible and
very unsafe laws in the United States
and we're going to be able to do
something about that hopefully soon
hopefully Congress will get their act
together and get in and create some very
powerful laws like Mexico has and like
Canada has and like almost all countries
if we don't have laws we have catch and
release you catch and then you
immediately release and people come back
years later for a court case except they
virtually never come back so what we are
preparing for the military to secure our
border between Mexico and the United
States we have a meeting on it in a
little while with general mattis and
everybody and I think that it's
something we have to do president Trump
earlier today responding to a question
about his plan to send National Guard
troops and the military to protect our
southern border here with reaction NRA
TV contributor former Secret Service
agent Dan bond Geno Fox News national
security strategist Sebastian Gorka
author of the brand new soon-to-be New
York Times bestseller the Geraldo show a
memoir and I had the honor of hosting a
party for her all the last night even
though we disagree on this issue
correspondent at large or all the Rivera
all right her although if you're gonna
have a caravan of people planning to
confront basically every border agent
this is now a national security threat
every agent will be at risk
Mexico is allowing this to happen when
they usually just throw people in
Central America out or in jail and if
Mexico does this they are allows this
they are responsible for anything that
happens at the border if people become
violent in my opinion your reaction
first of all you're not promoting a
civil war otherwise you wouldn't be
friends with me
I embrace your gracious generosity and
your hospitality and thank you so much
for the party last night Thank You
tastic for the book I just think that
this whole story of the caravan is is
tremendously high
for the last 10 years these this group
webelo seen from Paris people Without
Borders has been organizing these Easter
time marches to demonstrate the needs of
people to leave their homelands in this
case Honduras to flee and they want a
regulated approach they want more
immigrant rights and all the rest of it
this caravan was larger than most of
them but it's a thousand miles from the
US border it's already as you said at
the top of the program show on breaking
up the caravan is disbanding only but
the president's threatened Mexico though
well it could be that that's what put
pressure on it to stop it right there
but the women and children that comprise
most of this group they had no way of
getting to the US border they have no
money they have nothing they are fleeing
some severe economic if any repression
McCorkle if they don't stop this and
that group of people gets to the border
it's gonna be Mexico's fault if anything
happens because what you don't know when
you have crowds like that and they then
people saying publicly they think they
have a right to come in here illegally
legally it's it's Mexico's
responsibility and any nation that
they've traversed on their way to
America because if you are seeking
asylum if you're not just coming here
for our economy for our benefits then
you have to seek asylum in the first
country that provides it after you leave
your country
this is either a political stunt or
these people are simply being used and
look here Aldo mentioned it what's the
name of the organization people without
borders this is an ideological movement
remember what Hillary said in that
speech to the bankers the transcript of
which was leaked during the campaign she
said her dream was to have a borderless
Hemisphere no borders from Canada right
down to South America that's the left
globalist i ideal and in that case
America ceases to exist
yeah dan I gotta be honest we need this
in the military down there's precedents
to send the military down and this is a
national security issue
yes Sean we didn't militarized the
border the narco-traffickers and the
terrorists looking to kill us did a
trumpets just responding to that and you
know I disagree with Geraldo here - this
isn't hyper although you know listen you
you know this as well as I do let's not
run from this terrorists and
international groups coming from the
tribe border region in South America
that have used the corridor through
Central America into the United States
to funnel drugs to launder money and to
sneak terrorists potentially into the
United States they know about our vets
no no that is not true no this is
nothing one verify terrorist penetration
of the southern border did you that's
not that did you really the women and
children
Geraldo did you read the project I've
spent more time on that border than most
what you should refuse about it or
although you should really know as you
said conclusive into what an attorney
this is about the border wall this is a
negotiation I think people are being
hoodwinked this is a negotiation where
President Trump wants the border wall we
want the dreamers have a path to
citizenship this right now damn what
about us do we get a say you know I I
find that interesting you always talk
about illegal immigration in terms of
the effect on the illegal what about the
American population at taxpayer
financing this nonsense what about the
legal immigrants for although who
patiently waited in line through this
these people talk about in terms of the
illegal right let's give dr. Gork a
little last word I'm not trying to go
just to constrain to time look that
Dan's point is is a very important one
and the people who are hurt the most are
Americans and the person at the bottom
of the ladder is the recently arrived
immigrant and they they are harmed the
most by illegal aliens and that's just
we have zero unemployment how are they
hurting how are they hurting we have
zero unemployment because they come in
they work
can I answer they will work for a
fraction of what somebody who is here
legally like myself is they will
undercut because I'll be paid cash under
the table and that hurts real Americans
who build the wall built the dream
operable citizenship build the wall
alright we're going to leave it there
you have to view this in the citizenship
Thank You immigration Congrats on the
book